Hey,
what's going on?
It's bill burr and this is the Monday
morning podcast for Monday match third
2014.
I am recording.
I'm recording live as I always
do. Um, live to tape here.
Live to digital, whatever the fuck
it is. I'm here in Toronto, Ontario.
And that person yawning in the
background like a fucking old man.
I was his New Jersey.
The Pride of New Jersey,
Paul Versey. What's going on brother?
That's up math. It's going on.
How are you enjoying, uh, how
will you join enjoying a so well,
you know dude, the food right? We were
talking about the food here has been,
whenever you heard me say, I got to tell
you, put New York aside. Cause you know,
I'm a big New York food guy.
I mean the food here has been knocking
out of the Park Mattson been incredible.
Yeah. And Moncton and a in Halifax. We uh,
one of them was that, that
Ale house place. Um, oh,
the first place we went to the
pelvic triangle triangle. Yeah. Yeah.
We went over there for lunch. Well, first
of all, let's just back up for a second.
One thing I did want to bring up was
what's been fucking hilarious is Paul
Versey going through Canada, eastern
fucking Canada. We're literally,
we're driving to Moncton and Halifax.
I've never seen this in my life.
Like instead of a school crossing,
they literally had that same yellow
sign with the fucking Moose on it. Yeah,
I've never seen that.
Okay,
so typical Paul Versey
typical fucking New Yorker.
You just go places and that never done
this guy has been trying to order an
Arnold Palmer
everywhere we've gone.
Yeah.
And what's funny is you've
gone from saying confidently,
can I have an Arnold Palmer to now
you're just describing the ingredients.
It just does stare. They started off
like, can I get an Arnold Palmer?
And they would be like, what?
And He'd be like, I did that.
And it'd be like an Arnold
Palmer. I'm sorry, I don't know.
You know a ice tea lemonade, Arnold
Palmer. And they're like, no we don't.
I have that. You got to an ice
tea. No, we don't have that either.
So then the next time you
ordered it, um, they're like, oh,
what do you want for this? And then we go
to Halifax and you ordered it this way.
You Go, yeah, you got Arnold
Palmer, you know. Oh, well Palmer.
So I was squinting my eyes
like to yet lemonade thing.
You did that and then downstairs
in Toronto you just go, yeah.
I was wondering, um, do you
have lemonade and ice tea?
And you could maybe put those together
and they're like, yeah, no, no, we don't.
We don't know. I, I'm, I'm over three. I'm
all for three with the, all of the power.
So if you know that as I do,
why don't you order a stand?
Makita has probably some sort of fucking
drink up here and they absolutely,
of course we do. Yeah.
I'm just, I give up.
It's just going to be lemonade or ice
tea from now. I just fucking hilarious.
You have ordered everywhere
the first time when you said,
do you have an Arnold Palmer?
They like, well, yeah, yeah,
mostly lemonade and then just a splash
of ice tea. And I'm like, all right,
you hang out with law ahead.
Cause that's how law had,
well he gets more lemonade
too. Yeah, that's actually,
that's the one knock I'll give Canada.
That's the food's been great,
but not having lemonade.
It's unacceptable.
Fucking a letting and not have
lemonade because it's sub zero up here.
That's like some, some
summertime shit. Oh,
lemonade lemonade's year round lemonade.
It's incredible.
I'm not saying it's not good
fall. Yeah. With the first lady.
Did you see your face when you, do you
have stock in the lemonade? Do you like,
but lemonade is year round. Let me make
wonderful kid up the kid in a hell no.
The, the, the girl in mocked and I go,
can I get an Arnold Palmer? And she lived,
she froze up and she goes, UN UN Arnold.
And that's when I realized, dude,
you're out of the country,
man. You got to, yeah.
And then you kinda just
smirked and put your head down.
[inaudible] I knew you were like,
this is going to be a disaster.
Like they don't even golf up here.
They don't have golf up here.
If you notice there's no golf courses.
Yeah,
I guess it was a little crazy hilarious.
We drove by one the other day.
People golf up here like they
know who tiger woods. No they do.
But it's just funny that I use an American
golfer as a drink thinking that some
kid and in a waitress would know and
an American golfer from like the 60s,
that would be like somebody from Canada
go into like South Carolina in ordering
a rocket.
We showered 19 year old Canadian waitress.
Oh I bought the little stuck up.
Ah Shit.
Get the fucking airport this morning
in Halifax had in like the one,
the one jerk we've met in Canada. How nice
to the people in eastern Kansas. It's,
it's beyond are unbelievable.
They're over the top. Nice. Uh,
they've been great and I agree with you.
You know what you said something and I
didn't say it cause I thought you were
going to be like, you know, fucking
Versie complaining, but she, you know, I,
I you ordered a juice and then I ordered
one and I asked, how's the root beer?
I mean, how's the ginger one member?
I go, how's the Ginger Hammer?
And she just Kinda just goes, she goes,
she's looked at me, Derek. She goes,
I don't like ginger, so
you know, I don't like it,
but if you like Jennifer and I was out
right then I was out when she said that.
Yeah, no, she didn't.
She went and immediately detects
thing and I just started thinking, oh,
she must ain't even see your
text. Uh, she wasn't at one point.
She's one of those board hot chicks.
She's working at the fucking airport.
She's done. Yeah, it's over.
She looks in the mirror, she
goes, I'm better than this,
but I can't figure out a way
out yet, you know? Yeah. I mean,
there's gotta be addicted, jump
on or or, or something. Right.
She's probably going to,
what?
She's probably going to start fucking
stripping out there in eastern Canada.
What's a good name for a titty
bar? And he's can Canada Caribou,
clam shack,
whatever.
But dude, it was, you will fucking
hilarious when we go. Well, we first,
first of all,
I flew into,
I flew into a Halifax Moncton first night,
Moncton,
um, which is Mon C. T. O. N. I
finally can fucking spell it.
I hope I did it right though. From
La, right? Yeah. And this fucking,
you want to talk about having
tourettes I land in Montreal.
All right. And I don't know
if I mentioned it last week,
but I actually brought my hockey stuff.
I brought my hockey bag with
my fucking funny, my book,
because I set up a bunch of ammo.
I tweeted that I was,
I wanted to play when I was
up here. So all these people,
you know, come here, play,
come here, play. And everybody's going,
hey, I got stuff you can use stuff.
Don't worry. We'll buy it. We'll
buy you a new Jaque. And I'm like,
that's fucking disgusting. I'm
going to lug my shit up here. Right?
So I'm thinking all you gotta worry about
is I'm going to drag it out of the car
at lax as stick it on one of those
little fucking $2 things, right.
Wheel it to some guy.
He takes it and then I'm done.
And then when I land in Moncton,
I just fucking throw it on another one.
It's, it's not going to be that
big a deal. It's, it's annoying,
but it's not that big a fucking deal. So
what happens? I get to Montreal, right?
There's no cart anywhere.
I'm fucking,
I got the hockey bag on top of my wheelie
bag and I got my computer shift all my
mixer and the podcasts looking like a
complete asshole and in Montreal, right?
Oh No, no way in Montreal. The switch you
have to do. I figured I, I'd, you know,
I'd land in Montreal. I go through customs
and then I jump on a fucking plane.
You got to claim your fucking
bags. Uh, I dunno why.
I was like,
I guess it's like,
do you think I assembled a fucking
bomb when I was on the plane?
So I had a claim,
both those two asshole bags then drag
them back over to someplace else. Right,
and that part wasn't too bad. That's
still sucks. No, it's that. No,
but then I got back upstairs. I had to go
back through security again. It's like,
did I assemble a fucking gun on the plane?
Now he,
they admitted that to me there that,
it's funny you said that because
I said when I had the connection,
because I flew from New York to Montreal
and Montreal and I said to the guy who
I don't have to go. He goes and I said
he was really cool to teach the the,
I guess Tsa, I don't know. But
he goes, he goes, yeah. He goes,
our systems kind of screwed up here
that we don't have it right here yet.
That's what he said. Oh. He said, no. He
said that. He was like, and I was like,
Oh yeah, cause it doesn't matter.
What am I going to do from,
from the Tsa guy was cool with me too.
When I went there,
I actually had the paperwork. What are you
doing up here? I go, I'm doing stand up.
And he goes, yeah, the paper and gave
it to him. He goes, he just goes, great.
I wish everybody was like this
cause I'm doing just for laughs.
Suggest for lapse is like
the comedy thing of his.
So they know exactly what
you're supposed to have.
So it was so nice to come
to this country and not lie.
Cause I always lie when I get it. What
are you doing here? I'm visiting friends.
Yeah. Where do they live?
Near the stadium I got.
So I always do that because I don't
want to deal with, cause I, you know,
I never have the right paperwork that
happened to me when I was fucking going
into Scotland. I downloaded everything and
God knows, you know, I'm fucking it up,
but I'm blaming my, my reps,
you guys didn't show me the
right stuff. Yeah, we did.
We sent it three times.
So I always lie when I go into a country,
I'd just say I'm visiting friends.
It's weird when you're by yourself,
but if you say you're visiting friends,
um, and then they go, where do they live?
And all you need is a fucking address.
But I had that backfire because
I came up with a comic. I would,
I came up to do the comedy nest up
there. Jim Bo's room and uh, you know,
I probably should mention as an
act, it's fine. It's this rule man.
It don't matter if they're going
to see the warm socks, right? No,
it's a great room.
It's actually when you did a festival,
you work out there and stuff. But uh,
we went there, we went there to me,
what a host. We went there and
uh, we went there and they go,
what are you doing here? And a comic.
I'm with ghost. You just, just let me,
I'll just,
you know,
we're telling you all have visited
friends for the weekend and they go, yeah,
all right. Just wait here. Came back,
got the websites online,
saw that we were working at
the club and you're fucking,
how did they sat that called him and said,
next time you're not getting it.
Don't lie. Figure that out.
Typed in the name bullshit. Well,
I swear to God,
why don't you guys said it's not just oh,
typed and typed in the name
and then saw it and goes, Huh.
That's pretty all you know,
because anytime it's so fucking annoying,
can't get away with anything anymore.
I mean,
Jesus Christ back in the day you
had to do some Peter Falk Shit,
but I gotta just tell you, listen to this
and I just not adding up for a second.
Do you mind just standing? I mean,
I might be crazy, but they did it.
It's something, they look at your
shoes and they could figure it out.
You will fucking line. And now they just
say they have the answers to the test.
Paul, we're coming to your
country and enjoy ourselves.
You know that went the fuck.
It's like, you know, Hey Paul,
God forbid you come to Canada and
they don't squeeze a couple of Nicola.
You know what? Fuck these people
thought I was having a good time.
You know why I'm bringing
my American when I was just,
you're lucky you bringing my
dick jokes up to your fucking
frozen Tundra. So anyways,
so I land the night before,
um, land the night before
anyways, and uh, in Moncton.
And then the next day, uh, a buddy of mine
that I met at the Mario Lemieux things,
uh, camp said, if you have a
fucking come up here, I'll,
you know, I'll take you out.
And uh, went up and played
the middle of the day. Dude,
I've never done that on the road. Played,
played a pickup game, a hockey, right.
Right.
In a course I was,
I was such a fucking nonfactor
in the game as I always am.
I can skate. Okay, now
you could skate. Good man.
I could skate good compared to you, but
I'm not compared to a fucking Canadian.
I can't, no, dude, I you,
you're fucking, I got to just
talk. I don't want it. Let me,
let me finish real quick, just real
quick just to tell the people listening.
So I was such a nonfactor second to last,
you know,
time I'm out on the ice.
I actually blocked the shot just so I
would somehow have some positive thing in
one shift and I took it right off
the toe. Dude, you showed you my toe.
I'm going to put a post,
a picture of it by my hotel was purple.
Now part of that's because I'm a redhead
and I got an alabaster feet here so it
really shows up with your Greek skin.
I don't think you'd notice it as much,
but dude, it's like, like they
should for in medical school,
like if they ever just want to show like,
you know what do call it,
a contusion or a bruise,
whatever the fuck they want to call.
They should punch a redhead because
all the detailed comes out man.
Well, no, you're pale white.
So when you were like,
I got to show you the tow yesterday
house, he's like, let me first, let me
just, I'll, I'll look at it
but let me eat. But uh, no, I
just, I can, horrific brass.
Wanted to tell your listeners that the
size of bills hockey bag is so funny that
like you travel with this, you
know, we're, we're out here.
Hockey bags are just in general,
a gigantic, you have that.
Like you brought the equipment like
you care that much. And I love that.
I love that. Cause you got to do it to
have fun. I mean no, this is a thing too.
I have the number,
some old school podcast listeners.
Remember I used to advertise
skate fenders on my, Oh,
is that right on my podcast.
And as he's, you know,
it's one of the few places you don't
have protection if you get hit by the
fucking puck. Um, if you were in the
whole bird cage thing is, is on your feet.
And this guy did a study where like all
these, like how many manpower games,
you know,
um,
how much manpower you lost per game in
the Nhl due to foot injuries and people
getting hit with the puck. So we came up
with these things, scape fenders and uh,
they basically fit right on the side
of the plastic thing. And I just,
I brought him and I psyched
myself up going, I don't
give a fuck. I'm a comedian.
I can't be limping around on stage.
I'm not trying to get anywhere in
this sport and just having fun.
I'm wearing these things. And I got there
and I fucking gave into peer pressure.
I'm like, nobody else has them on.
I've never even seen anybody with,
I guess some people in the Nhl where him,
so I don't, where the fuck are things?
I've never taken a shot
like that off my foot ever.
Did it hurt when it happened or did
it hurt after? Like it was weird.
It hurt like hell and then all of a
sudden it felt really warm and it actually
felt kind of good.
Yeah,
I finished my shift and then I fucking
sat down and then I was thinking like,
is this thing going to make
me limp? Fortunately I haven't
went, but uh, you know,
my, I could bend it and everything. It's
fine. It's just, it's Barney the dinosaur.
Purple Gross. Yeah. Yeah,
yeah. That's fucking bad.
So I wouldn't have worn them either.
I would have done what you did if
I saw nobody with the guards. I'm,
I'm not put this fucking box analysis.
Yeah.
And then on top of that I was in
another country, so it's like, oh these,
it was pussy Americans. They fucking
come up dead dress like Lindy rough.
Um, that's funny man. Hang on a second.
I actually for should have
said fucking off Samuelson.
He used to wear the most fucking peds.
I just remember long time ago Fred Cusack.
So we gave Lindy referred cheap shot
and on the Bruins and it's an even,
it was such a fucking cheap shot that
even the color commentator had to be like,
wow, you know, that was kind of
cheap. And then Frey Cusick goes,
well you have to hit him.
He's so well protected.
So anyways,
we're up here and I'm trying to see how
much time we're doing cause I got to
know when to fucking read. Yeah. I got to
read a little bit advertising here. Um,
well when, when, when we come back from
the advertising, I'm going to talk to a,
we're going to talk about Paul Versey
actually bought a pair of skates up here.
Uh Oh yeah. All right. Hang on
a second. Hang on, hang on, hang
on. Okay. Where are we? Paul, you
ever heard me read out loud before?
No, this is bad. Oh, maybe I'll just let
you know. It's all your respect for me.
It's going to go out the window.
All right.
stamps.com everybody getting your mailing
and shipping done can seem like a no
win situation.
Going to the post office takes up
valuable time leasing a postage meter,
expensive with the multiyear. Come with
multiyear commitments and hidden fees.
Luckily I know a better way.
What is it?
stamps.com stamps.com buy and print
official US postage for any letter or
package right from your desk using
your own computer and printer.
Even get special postage discounts.
You can't find it.
The post office plus stamps.com is more,
is more powerful than a postage
meter at just a fraction of the cost.
You can save up to 80% compared to a
postage meter and you'll avoid those time
consuming trips to the post office.
I use stamps.com for all my DVDs that
for some reason I'm still trying to sell
on the road my posters or whatever other
crap I'm trying to sell after the show
and I'm a moron and I've been able
to figure it out so you can too.
Right now use my last name,
birth for this special offer,
no risk trial plus $110 bonus offer,
which includes a digital scale and
up to $55 free postage. Don't wait.
Go to stamps.com before you do
anything else and click on the
microphone@thetopofthehomepageandtypeinburburthatstamps.com
enter
[inaudible]
that's not bad. That was good. That
was one over. That was good. I hit,
I hit the fucking sand trap once.
All right. Dollar Shave Club,
dollar shave club. You keep the
score here pro. Whenever I fuck up,
that's a stroke against. I started
off even. All right, here we go.
Dollar Shave Club.
Okay guys,
you've heard me talk about how much I
love Love Dollar Shave club.com so why
haven't you joined like you don't have
anything better to do than go to the
store or anything better to do than spend
your hard earned money on the razors.
What's wrong with you?
It's very aggressive copy this week.
I like it and the last two years,
dollar shave club.com has saved hundreds
of thousands of guys time by delivering
amazing quality,
amazing razors and high quality
grooming products right to their door.
Go to dollar shave club.com forward
slash birch shave with their razors.
I'm a four x guy,
but my buddies swears by his
executive that's supposed to be me.
Why do they do that? Why do they just
have me lie you Ron Burgundy or you?
Everything that's on the promise for x
guy. My buddies swears by his executive,
look, they're great razors at
the price this supposed to be.
You don't have to make up lies.
Swami Da Dollar Shave Club anyways.
Not only do they have great raises,
be sure to check out Dr cabbies.
Easy Shave Fun. Seriously.
This stuff is amazing.
It makes shaving feel like just
softly wiping whiskers off your face.
I don't know who wrote that,
but that's brilliant.
And you can't forget about one wipe
Charlies. The Butt wipes from men.
That's right.
It's a buttwipe for men.
Peppermint tangle enough said.
Uh, what are you waiting for?
You can't get deliveries every year.
Yeah,
you can get deliveries every other month
if you need and you can cancel anytime.
If you don't like it.
Dollar Shave club.com once you,
once you to be great and keep the extra
pocket, uh, extra cash in your pocket.
Jesus, Paul, I'm in the water. Uh,
I'm a member of dollar shave club.com.
Now it's your turn, shave time,
shave money, dollar shave club.com.
Go to dollar shave club.com forward slash
bar to let them know that I sent you.
That's dollar shave club.com forward
slash bur bur or go to [inaudible] dot com
and click on the dollar shave club
banner. What was my score on
that one for? For slip ups?
Not Bad. Yeah, but that's on one hole.
Multiply that times 18 what do you have
there, Paul? Oh man, that's tough. Huh?
What is that? What would that be?
Paul? Come on. You're good at math.
That's like four under 80 it's like,
it's like,
what is it like 67 76 18
times. Wait, what'd you say?
18 Times three times four is the 76 well
18 times 20 would be 80 minus eight.
It'd be 72 [inaudible] 72 but you
know, whatever. Yeah. Just shoot.
What the fuck dude, what do you
care who? I mean, who are you?
I mean who am I am just uh,
Johnny Sanchez.
Oh. So anyways, hey, I got, I got to
do it. I called it this week. Oh yeah.
What was it say going to mean Shit to you?
Cause it's not sports,
but it's a different thing.
It was a drummer.
I've been telling people for years to
watch this guy, Mike Johnson's, uh,
Mike johnston.com Mike's lessons.com.
Sorry. Um, his drum lessons. He was just,
he was the best guy right out of
the gate when Youtube started.
He just immediately had the best,
like most informative,
explained it the best,
played the best as far as the instructors.
The guy was just head and
shoulders above everybody.
And I've been telling people
to go to this guy's, you know,
website and sign up for
his lessons and all that.
And this month he's on the cover.
Oh, modern drummer magazine.
They've never had, they've never
had a drum instructor on the cover.
That's a good camp. I called it
ever that you go look at that Paul.
It's not just with sports. That's a good
dude. I called it and is even better.
So I get the issue and I, uh, you
know, I, I of course, you know,
opened it to read the whole article on it.
And as I'm going through,
I see this other article and I'm
looking at this guy's face go,
and I know that fucking guy.
Who was that?
And it was sandy genero now
sandy genero taught at the,
uh, he's laughing about something else
he taught at or it's still teaches at the
drummer collective. And I took
lessons for him like 10 years ago.
Big Time Yankee Fan.
I was taking lessons with them.
My Oldest Sandy Gennaro would you say?
I Dunno, I dunno how old he is, Paul.
You don't do that in show business. He
looks phenomenal and he plays even better.
He's a great guy,
despite the fact that he's a Yankee Fan.
So I used to take lessons
from him this not long ago.
It was like I was taking lessons with
them with Don Zimmer tried to attack Pedro
Martinez and he grabbed fucking dawn
by his head and just use this momentum.
The ground. He did not
push that man. That's still
fucking, that's still a little,
what was his, what was he supposed to do?
Paul? Just step out of the way, you know,
and then what guy by his
head and then what he puts,
she pushed him down on
the nice soft grass.
Did you ever see that grass,
that grass at Fenway park is a
blend of Kentucky blue grass.
What would you have? Argentina. Green.
What would you have done if Paul Zimmer,
we'll, I'll, I'll do,
I'll do the bit that I was doing back
in the day and I used to do this in New
York and it would kill front of Yankee
fans. All right. I'll say, Oh man,
you see what Pedro did to Don Zimmer
and that'd be a Booboo, and I was,
I would say that it was a red sox fan
and this is how I explained it. I said,
look, went don Zimmer ran at
him. He had three options,
either one runaway and then he's the pussy
that ran away from an 80 year old man
to punch the guy in the face,
which you're not going to do that because
then you punched an old guy or three,
grab him by his Macy, Dave head and just
sorta guide them down to the ground.
You saw him afterwards.
Yeah,
on simmer was crying saying he shouldn't
have done it. He lost his composure.
Now he did lose his composure. That
was, he looked like a of old bulldog.
If you took his chew
toy. Yeah, that was bad.
You know what the whole thing was bad
because Don Zimmer, he's basically,
you know from the top of his head to
his toes, his baseball. Did he get,
he got married.
How cool is his wife?
Like he got married
like at a baseball park.
Like they were walking like
all the players were standing
there with bats making
like an arch and he would walk in
underneath it. So that was the bad thing.
But you know his legacy after that many
years though is the Pedro Martinez.
It is. It's throwing. No, but
they've, I mean they talk about it.
You can't let it Don Zimmer without
thinking that I do. Cause he also,
he coached us, he played on the bumps
that want it and 55 you know, Paul's,
you know your history. I don't know
if you know your sports history.
You always give me shit. Well, I was
born in 68 how the fuck would I not,
how would I know the 55 Brooklyn Dodgers?
How would I know that? I, you know,
I'm one of those guys that
I guess I just cared after.
I just cared when I was
able to watch selfish. Yeah.
Anyways, so I read through and
I see Sandy Gennaro. I'm like,
Holy Shit, this is the guy I used to
take lessons with. He's such a great guy.
He's the first guy that showed me a
technique to try to do some of that.
Those bottom triplets. Just
a fucking great guy. Um,
journeymen drummer, who's,
he's played with everybody.
He's fucking play with every,
his first group he started off with
the lead singer was Michael Bolton.
It was like a rock group. I forget
what they words wisely. Yeah.
They got some of their
videos up there and, uh,
and then he became like a hired gun,
uh, pat Travers band. Cindy Lopper,
the monkeys, like all
that pops. He's done.
Pat Benatar was a Pat Benatar,
Joan Jett. I can't remember.
He's got a bunch of great
stories or whatever. So, um,
so anyways, so I'm like, Oh,
Fuck Sandy. Gennaro. I gotta, I
gotta watch some of his videos.
So I look it up and I find this
fucking video that I sent you.
This is why Paul is laughing.
When I brought up Sandy Generra because
sandy is from Staten Island and this,
this guy interviewing him
from Staten Island. I gotta,
I gotta put this video up
there because when I have to,
when I think of a stereotypical New
Yorker Dude, it sounded like too,
is that kid Bobby a on an SNL,
Bobby Moynihan,
this like right in his wheelhouse,
like this is a character he would
do and that was all excited.
He was so excited to meet Sandy Gennaro.
This is how he does the interview.
He goes,
oh my God,
I'm standing in Santee genero this guy,
he's played with everybody. Sandy to
tell us about some of the interviews,
get
he ends his question going,
Gad, get everything he said.
So when you were like coming up in rock,
you know when rock and roll and who,
which drummers really
influenced you again, guy. Yeah,
I think he only said it once, but I
was like, when I saw that, I was like,
Bobby Moynihan would take that little
little thing and we would turn that until
I told you Monaghan did guy Fieri. I got
to see the diner's dives and whenever,
yeah,
that's it.
He's got the hair spiked back and he was
like at the chin hair and he does the
whole, you got this guy and
he's got the enthusiasm.
That's my favorite thing that
Bobby did was when he was doing,
they were showing the different kind of
drunk people at, at the concert. Oh neat.
Did the drunk point and guy and they
started playing the song ants marching,
that dat, Dat, Dat, Dat, dat, Dat, dat.
He was doing it then when he's drunk and
he was like pointing towards the stage.
It's a fucking visual. You've got
to see him do it. And you know,
it's funny as I've been to a zillion
concerts and seeing that guy and I never
really thought about it,
but when he did it,
I fucking died laughing going like I've,
I've seen that guy a zillion times.
So anyways, so there you go Paul. That's
my big, my big, my big weekend in my,
my hobby there. The drum world. I got
to uh, well I came into your little hot,
you got me into this hockey
thing this week, man.
To you fucking buying those
skates was the funniest shit ever.
It was like my wife trying
to find a pair of shoes.
This fucking guy tried on like you
supposed to, well first of all,
only Canada has a, has a selection
and a wall like that. We go into the,
and that was a shit one two cause they
said the best one was down in Halifax.
That was a shit one. Well they would,
shit is fucked. You know what it was,
it was a shit time to go in
because it was, it's almost spring.
It's fucking hilarious.
It's like minus 30 out here and
it's like springtime for them.
They had a wall top to bottom,
every brand and it was $700 skates there.
There was $700, $300. And I'm like, look,
I haven't been on skates
and I'm 11 years old.
So I'm thinking I'm going
to go in and get like $60
and you kinda like you kinda you.
I hope my wife doesn't listen to this.
I spent a little money. Uh,
but she goes, I fucking with
dude, whatever. I'm kidding.
I'm, I'm that one. I'm afraid
my wife, right? Yeah. Yeah.
The support your Freddy away if that's
okay. You don't have to back pedal line.
No,
but listen,
it is kind of crazy to spend money on
skates when you haven't done it, you know,
in, in how many years and
then you're going, listen,
you're good. You got, you got,
you could, you didn't like peer
pressured me into it, but you just go,
those are good. They'll last
forever. And in my mind I'm like,
I'm going to have these for 20 years.
So then I was like, get me this,
get me this pair.
And they didn't have my size.
And then I finally got these and you
were giving me shit saying I was being a
diva, trying to get a
pair of ice skates. But
one thing he and I had to literally walk
away because I'm one of those people,
Paul,
like the second I finished a meal,
I get up and I leave and I've
been working on doing that.
I don't know if you've noticed on this
tour that I've actually sit there like,
dude, I'm scattered brain. Like I'm
already, I'm like finishing my last bite.
Stacy says I get up and leave and she
goes, can we enjoy this? Our water?
Can we just enjoy the rest of this? And I,
but I like to sit to now. Oh okay. Yeah.
Yeah. So I'm trying not to do that
shit. So I'm seeing you just keep like,
like some wine connoisseur keeps
sending these fucking skates back.
So I literally,
and I'm,
and I want to get down to Halifax because
I got something that's another place
where I can skate. Cause my old
things, I'm not going to booze.
I'm going to skate on this fucking thing.
I'm actually going to lose weight for
once and not become Billy fat face on the
fucking road. You could do
that having a couple of drinks,
but we'll talk about that. A hilarious,
Paul's trying to twist my arm. I've,
I've got, I've got, I got 35 days
in pork. I'm, I'm 53 today. Okay.
I haven't hit my wife in seven weeks and
you're going to have to go back to the
drink.
We can't not how so anyways,
so I literally,
I'm walking up acting like I'm
checking the car to make sure nobody in
unbelievably friendly Canada
is going to steal that.
Well either you go first,
you go out,
we're going to go check the car and
then you go, no, the car is fine.
You even said no, the car's fine.
And then when the third pair,
when I had to change the third paragraph,
I'm going to check the car.
It's always a deal. So I come walking
back in and I'm literally just going,
all right, stay calm, stay calm, don't
lose your shit. Don't pressure this guy,
he's buying skates. He's going to fuck
up his feet if he buys the wrong ones.
Don't be a selfish Dick Cause you want
to drive down to Halifax. Who I now,
so I come walking in there and you
have on another pair of skates and I'm
thinking like, okay, he looks
pretty happy. I'm like, I'm like,
how do they feel Paul? And you're
like, you know the right ones. Good.
But the left one is there's something
that's pushing against my toe.
It's kind of there was pushing
against my toe, but he even felt it.
And he went in and he said they're
all like that. And he goes,
they're all like that. And he
goes, put your heel back there.
You've got to slam your
heel down and then tight,
tight right around your
ankle and your toes.
Your toes supposed to be feathering the
end. There we were. That's what he said.
Don't let your toes for how
excited where we walk in.
Because also that was then
we'd drive down to Halifax.
I'm driving fucking versing
nuts cause I'm doing,
what did I do on like 140 kilometers?
Who speed 140 kilometers in? Uh,
what kilometer zone was it?
I don't know.
But you were speeding and it was snowing
out and we even saw a truck fish till
you were scaring the shit out of me.
Oh yeah.
There's always a guy in a pickup who
fucking goes off the road always in pickup
because I've got four wheel drive,
no worry about it.
And he went right off
pay you at one point.
I got you fish tail one at one time and I
go, man, you gotta. Yeah, that wasn't me.
That was the snow. That was
dumb when I just said, yeah,
that's way not supposed to be speed and
you fucking idiot. You even said you.
I could feel your nervous as I was
scared, man. Now you have a way.
When I'm driving too fast,
you have a way about you.
You sit in this fucking way
where you don't grab your leg,
right, but you put your hand on
the side, that's fovea leg in you.
All your fingers are all spread apart.
Like you're getting ready to fucking
squeeze the material and I pants pants on
an airplane to like,
it's going to matter like the
grip or my hand is going to stop.
I slowed down to about 120 kilometers.
You, you were like in a row. You were,
you were in a rush to get to hell because
the public skate was at four o'clock
and then we had two shows. So we
show up down in Halifax, right?
Get another fucking unbelievable meal.
Unbelievable fucking fit.
And it wasn't even the best place. Now
let me tell you something, since it was,
the fucking hotel place was incredible.
Let me tell you something right now.
If you guys are ever in Halifax and you,
and you stay at the Atlantica Halifax,
it was the best.
What one wants the Atlantic? It was
the Atlanta, Atlanta in Halifax.
It was the best fucking seafood
chowder I've ever had in my life,
in my life. I couldn't believe what
I was eating. I couldn't believe it.
I was eating. I told you, I said if my
dad ever bit as he'd start crying. So he,
yeah. And I, I had scallops or something
like that was an unbelievably fresh,
right. So, ah, so then we'd
go down to the, the, the, the
front desk and I go, yeah,
we wanted to escape. I'm waiting for them
to laugh at US thing. I, yeah, I go where?
How do you drive? There they go. It's
right over there. He can walk to,
it was right there pointing across the
fucking go there with thinking it's going
to be an indoor rink. It's sleeting
outside, not sleeping. It was more no one.
Right.
So we fucking walk down there and all of
a sudden I just see in the distance out
in this field is fucking Zamboni
driving around and I'm going, Paul,
I think it's a, I think it's outside.
And you're like, no, no, no, no.
It's inside, it's inside. And I'm like,
I don't think that guys like fucking
doing donuts with that thing.
I was in denial about it. I go,
maybe there's one next to it inside.
I know you didn't have gloves or anything.
It's fucking hilarious.
So we go down there and says giant oval.
Yeah. Giant House. Cool though. Man.
I just wish it wasn't snowing cause
the ice stumps like a race track.
It wasn't like a big open rank.
Yes. It was like you go around,
it was like it like in the Olympics,
the speed skating thing,
it was fucking unreal. I was nervous
so I was nervous because like,
you know when you go inside with a rink,
I could fall into the boards,
I could skate into the boards of grab it
and then I knew that there was nothing.
So that's why he's supposed to skate
on the outside. That's what he said,
skate on the outside because they had
the railing and I felt good. But uh,
I was joking last night on stage I go,
I go burrs one of these guys, you know,
he's not admitting he's
good. I go to me, can I go?
He was spinning around like
Dorothy fucking Hamill out there.
I picked it up though, right? Yeah
you did. You did grab by the first,
your first time out there you are great.
I told you I was glad I didn't have
a helmet because I felt, I was like,
don't crack your head.
Don't crack your head.
And if I had a helmet I might be like,
well I spent, I spent $80 on a helmet.
You know what, you're going to use
it right now. It's been good so far.
So I got a,
I got a couple more games lined up
a pickup games, which is the shit.
Um, well I'll watch it.
I mean I'll, I'll, I'll,
I'll go skate in the corner like that,
you know, I'm the one. Yeah. You know,
go watch me fucking play hockey with
people who actually know how to play and
you'll see that whole Dorothy Hamill,
uh,
idea that you have of me is going to be
out the fucking window fall on my face.
What would happen if you gave me a stick
and I had to concentrate on a puck?
Be a nightmare. Well at least you
probably wouldn't fall down as much.
You didn't fall down at all.
But then if you've got the stick
that kind of helps you stay up. Yeah,
I got him admit it's weird
skating without a stick. Oh. Like,
I don't have confidence skating backwards
without a stick to something about it.
I'm just used to that.
Yeah. I don't know why.
And having all my stuff on. So if I fall
down, I know bruise like Mike, Mike,
my toe. You know how bad a fucking, how
about that guy who was dressed nice.
Oh, the guy looked like he
was going out to the club.
Guy looked like he was going to a wedding
reception. He was so good at skating.
Oh,
he looked like he was going,
he had like nice pants on and he
was just whipping around there.
He wasn't sweating it off.
No,
probably it went right to the club got
blown and that fucking left showed up to
the club holding them. Exactly.
Hey, by the way, that we, uh,
we want to thank everybody who came
out to the show so far on this tour. A,
we're having a great fucking
time up here. And, uh,
even the New York or Paul Versey,
he's saying that he loves Canada.
We're having a great time up here. Um, a
lot of people make fun of this country.
I don't know why I like them.
You know what I like about these guys is
Russia's going into the Ukraine and you
can, you know, and they can sit here
and shake their heads like, wow,
we don't approve of that, but they're
not going to be like, you know,
Canada never really has gotten involved.
Right.
Canada has never been one to get
involved on how well they'll,
we drag them into our fucking message.
Like a bunch of their guys have gotten,
I've gotten killed over
and the Middle East,
if you watched the hockey night in Canada,
Don Cherry shows him all the time.
It's fucking brutal. Yeah, it
was. They actually show him,
we don't show him down there because
after they all the college kids protested
Vietnam and you know, they'd
figure it out. Well don't
show this shit on the news.
So they just, you know, and
then this rag him, that's funny.
They're like the neighbor that like is
laid back and doesn't want to go out to
the club and we're like, no,
just, yeah, no. Starting to fight.
We start a fight like right Paul White
Canada. You think that too, right?
Yeah. I mean Kinda, I don't know
if we had to resort to violence.
Yeah. So anyways, uh, how far into this
thing am I? Can I get in with the, uh,
the questions here? What do we have any
other stories? Were about 35 minutes then.
Hang on one second. I appreciate you
doing this fucking video. I mean,
video the fucking podcast here because,
uh, telling you, man, I fucked up my,
Oh, this road rage yelling
last weekend. I fucked it up.
So I'm trying to avoid
here. Um, all right,
let's get into the questions
here for this week.
Uh,
alcohol and cardiac health. All right,
so here it is. So, so far. So by the way,
this is a perfect topic. It is, isn't it?
Yes. It's a pleasant topic because, well,
this is the lungs and the longest have
hung out with you without absolutely
destroying my liver. No, I was just on
the phone. My wife and I said, stays.
Not one drop of alcohol, not one gene.
She believed, you know, she goes, yeah.
And I go and I go, not only
that, I had seven fucking salads,
I said I've eaten seven salads,
I've eaten seven salads and
I've had not one drink alcohol.
I haven't had a cigar. I have
been an angel. But you know what?
The buck stops here. Okay,
I'm telling you right now,
devil is tossed one of the greatest lines.
One of the greatest lines ever said.
We were out,
we were smoking a cigar without booze.
Zoe weren't, no we weren't. We weren't.
We were, we were driving out to
the fucking Gig and Long Island,
we've always before the cigar,
we're driving out to a giggle long tent.
We had the, uh, the, the
Westbury music fair. And,
and we're sitting and we're talking about
how we haven't drank and we're talking
about cigars. And a bill starts
the sentence with this. He goes,
but poor man, I gotta tell Ya. And I'm
thinking the next thing out of his mouth,
I feel great. I don't want
to drink anymore. And he
just goes, I gotta tell you,
man.
Okay,
the devil inside of me is
tossing and turning. And I said,
that is a fucking movie
line. I said, Scorsese,
fucking terantin.
I'll have to hear that.
The devil inside devil
tossing and turning.
You know the devil tossing and
turning. Ah, great. Lion Brewery.
Like I said yesterday, I go are two devils
are in some room right now. Just going,
what the fuck?
Let us out.
We've had,
we've basically been up here on a kind
of a mandate is what we've been doing so
far. It's been fucking ridiculous. Reading
Salad. I'm going to bed at like fun,
gone a better only drinking
water. I'm drinking water
like it. It's just, you know,
you know it was hilarious was when we
went into that bar after in in Moncton
nightmare. Like how hammered
those people got. Oh my God.
And seeing how drunk I know and I
don't judge them because I look and go,
that's what I do. But you never get
locked. I've done that. Oh No, no.
They were friendly. Drunk.
They were friendly. Draw
people touching you shoulder.
No, I don't like that. No, no, no. I yell.
I can yet like there's a point
where I get drunk. I'm a,
I'm a happy drunk but if I get
drunk in this, somebody that just,
I dunno what they just fucking,
no,
you turn it to bleacher creature fan
when you get like really that supporting.
Yeah, you're a yeller. Hello?
Like you yell, he does every
syllable at the Alabama Lsu gets
the dream ends tonight and all of these
like Crimson people who were wearing
dockers and like are looking at them
going, what is he talking about?
I didn't know what there was.
I didn't know the sec was like that.
I thought they will fucking, I
didn't realize it was such like, no,
you said something about someone's,
they're so quiet at one time you cause
you never, you never sent it to bear.
But one time you,
you said something about someone's
like a mother but you didn't say about
someone's direct mother. You were
just like Jesus. No, you were like,
fathers are good now you said
something about that like,
but not like direct and one guy just goes,
well like they just
looked at you like that.
There were so horrified there was so
horrified. It was so funny. And then,
and then the time you,
you actually made me embarrassed
and blush almost when you,
what you did to the kicker of the Miami
Dolphins, that Guy Carpenter last year.
Like, I'm, I'm sitting there, I'm
sitting there. I'm the comic. I get,
I think things are funny.
I'm drinking and you're just relentless.
Hey, carpet, carpet there.
Everyone was at the
Cincinnati Bangles gaming.
Everyone's looking at bill and I'm
leaning away from him and value
carpenter. You're a liability
carpenter. Yeah. That field goal kicker.
Get your real estate license and
you had half the people laughing
and I'm going, bill is fucking,
it made the Bengals fan said,
get on that guy carpenter. He said, he
said yeah. And it was a close game. So,
you know, no, they were all into
it, but I was like, oh my God.
He was the chairman for the home team.
He's going in.
Oh, that's too bad. I say, that's why
I gotta be honest with you. Like I, uh,
I'm liking, like live in like this. I'm
going to fuck it up tonight. Tonight,
we're actually in Toronto and we're
going to the maple leaf's game. Um,
and I've been trying to explain to Paul
what an absolute honor and privilege it
is to somehow score may believe
tickets because I have hookups.
Um,
like literally NHL Office,
I blogged for them so they still know a
couple of people over there and I never
hit him up for tickets or whatever.
But like the maple leafs are the
only ones they don't give a fuck.
Like they just like, yeah, no, there's
no tickets. No. Somebody told me,
have you been to a cat? Have you been
to a hockey game in Canada before?
And I said No. And they go,
it's another, it's a whole
other level. Oh, it's awesome.
Like it's fucking awesome. They
go not really. And they, they,
they obviously it's their game.
They know the game.
They won the men's and women's gold.
Oh we talked yesterday.
Being in Canada lets me know when
a son and father escaped together.
It's like the equivalent of a father and
son throwing the ball in the backyard,
playing baseball. Like, you know,
I've never seen a store that has that
many hockey skates. Like everything has,
hockey was that oval thing. I've never
seen anything like that. That was all,
I thought that was the coolest fucking
thing ever. Like I always like,
like that's the kind of shit.
Like if I have a move back east,
I would build that in my bag.
I would build a backyard hockey ranked.
There's no fucking way.
I wouldn't goddamn global warming
by the time I fucking do it.
I'm not going to be able to have to
fucking live in the Yukon to do it. Um,
all right, let's do, uh, let's
do some, uh, some questions
here for this week. Uh, ALC.
Yeah, this right. And that's
what set this whole thing off.
Alcohol and cardiac health.
Hey,
Billy cream tits
insult me every week.
This is the worst thing that they like me,
uh,
for a couple of years in a row during
lent, I abstained from alcohol.
It sucked, but it felt good to challenge
myself. I did this because all my life,
I've always heard that total abstinence,
abstinence is the best health.
However,
recent research has shown that moderate
drinkers actually have reduced risk for
coronary heart disease up to
29% lower than total abstainers.
Although researchers aren't clear
as to why it's food for thought.
If I were you, if I were you, I would
have a damn drink. If, if you want one.
I know it's tough sometimes
to drink in moderation.
I simply try hard to not binge anymore.
Having said that,
you are probably healthier having the
occasional cocktail rather than the
occasional cigar. Uh, you might
actually live longer. Loved the show,
have fun in Canada, come back to the
bay area and go fuck yourself. Um,
that's not a new study.
That's a study that they've been
saying forever that you know,
one glass of wine is supposed to be good.
And I agree with that 100%.
That's the carrot cake we had. You know,
that's the carrot cake. You got to do it.
You got to do it, you know,
because then you binge.
Are you going to explain to the
listeners with the carrot cake was
oh yeah. So sorry. So I'm
like talking to, you know,
the carrot cake was when
we went to that place,
when we had that ridiculous
lunch and mocked in the
first day we were there. And,
um, I asked for the Arnold pulses and
when we went skating together, no, no, no.
This is what we had carrot cake
together. This the spinner trip, dude,
there's no fucking ridiculous.
I'm starting to become this guy that
needs a dessert with the next SIG free and
Roy, no, you're not like this.
You're not a coffee dessert guy.
But as I'm getting older,
I don't know what it is,
but after I eat a good meal,
I need a piece of chocolate or something.
My Dad was the same way.
So we go to this bar,
we eat this great food,
and I saw angled triangle thing and I say
to the lead trying to, and I said, look,
let you know, do you have
something? And she goes, well,
we got this carrot cake and I'm at an
Irish pub. And I'm like, you know what?
Everything was great. I bet you this
is great. This is delicious. So I go,
all right, bring the carrot cake over.
She gives a big piece. I go, Bill,
you want half of this thing? I don't
want any adult thing. He goes, sure,
we bite this fucking thing and I'm going.
And then afterwards you go, yeah man,
we were really healthy except
for the carrot cake and that,
that question is right. That
question is 100% right. You
got to do it, dude. How about
the fact that it was homemade?
It was deleted desserts. A
homemade, sorry, that's my
fucking phone. It's delicious.
And I, she's come on, come on enough.
I'm sorry. Yeah. So I agree with the
occasional, you know, the wine a day,
a couple of drinks. Look, if we go out
and have three to four cocktails tonight,
okay, just stay clean and next
thing, you know what I mean? No,
I don't know what you mean because I do
that and then the next time I go on a
nice little run I'm not
drinking is like two,
three years later because I
just, you know, you can't,
you can't, you don't have a couple
of new in this tour is over.
Go back on the thing.
I mean that hasn't been my pattern.
I enjoy it Paul. And what? I'm at a point
now where I haven't done it in a while,
so now I'm kind of enjoying not doing it
and I'm afraid to go back to doing that
now cause I'm not,
cause I'm literally an alcoholic just
because of all the extra fucking bullshit
that comes along with it. What you
do, although whatever, who's, well,
I'm not,
I'm not gonna fucking dwell on this shit
anymore because I know I'm going to go
back to drinking. So what the fuck
[inaudible] against the gars dude,
I gotta tell you something right now.
A Segarra week is not bad for you.
I'm going, I'm going to say
as a cigar weeks and up fee.
And you can say that without doing
any research. I love it. No, no, no.
That's 52 cigars a year. It's
a joke. What does that, well,
I'm not inhaling anything. I'm going to
do what you're putting into your mouth.
Right.
And then I wash my mouth that it's like,
it's like 10 cigarettes for your mouth.
That that study's horseshit.
It's not a study. My dentist
said it to me. Oh, okay.
So then the taste is kind of in
the medical field. I mean he,
maybe he knows a doctor.
Where can somebody say not inhaling a
cigar is like smoking 10 cigarettes.
No, no, no, no. He said for your
mouth. He's saying you're not,
it's not bad for your lungs.
Look to Michael Douglas was a big
time cigar smoker and that guy,
he had throat cancer.
He had that Paul,
you're putting fucking smoke in your
mouth. But I mean sports a nigger,
they say smokes like four a day every
day of his life. He's fine. You know,
I told you, that's why I think
you got to do it for a while.
That Guy Hamo in Boston. Oh my
God. Showed you the picture of him.
This guy designed it was this
guy designed a cigar jewelry.
Was it north end? Is
that Boston? Yes. Yeah.
So the north end of
Boston now only has the,
only has the only cigar bar lounge in
Boston now because they closed the other
one. So it's the north end and
it's a great place. And He,
the mayor of Boston was in there.
All these politicians were in there.
It was hysterical. And that the owner
has the fake Tan and Pinky rings.
And how you don't hate it,
he's kissing, you know,
he's kissing guys on the cheek like,
and it's so funny how he and Glenn,
thank you guys. Thank you guys for coming
out. Did you, did you enjoy? So yeah,
I to go, oh, come, this is the
place you come to this place.
And then he's got this little friend
named Hama and he goes and I go, hey,
what's that man? Is that hey,
they sell jewelry here. It's
my, it's my, it's my, uh,
you know, I don't own, I just own
this here. And he had cigar cufflinks.
He had a cigar.
Everything was cigar.
He had a cigar ring and it was a
diamond ash tray with, uh, with, uh,
a white gold cigar on it in a Red Ruby
to indicate the lit that it was lit and
the cigar and I go use when he
goes, everything's, I'm not,
I'm not joking or trying to be fun.
He goes every month I was there with
the matter reason. My brother, he goes,
everything's a guard.
He said to the three things you'd like
to go to my kids plussy [inaudible] and
it was the funniest and he
was dead serious. And he
goes, he goes four to five,
minimum day, six minimum because
I smoked nine a day bill,
he pulled out the sixth, one of the
night, his, I go, how am I going to do,
how many is that for you?
He goes, this fix, right?
I swear to God it was a size of a fucking
cucumber and he's just smoking it and
he's going, you want, you want
to $80 a stick. You want it.
This is the best is to vest.
I saw a guy outside of firehouse on
eighth avenue when I was in New York.
I walked by and I know I smelled this ago.
I always get to turn my head like, God,
Jesus Christ. It's good.
Let me get to the point.
It's like here in high heels on the
floor, you just have to look, you know,
and now when I smell the cigar,
I got to look to see like look at the
band to see what the stuff, I looked,
this guy, it looked like he
was smoking a pickle brown.
It was like he could, he couldn't
put it between his two fingers.
He had a hold it like serious, like a
fun. I never seen anything like it. Wow.
Fucking, I even know how he lit
it to fireman. It's fucking elite.
Probably lit it at his
last fire and like I said,
like a house had to be on fire so we
could actually like this fucking thick.
I would seek to those guys
are bad. I would think that
those guys have a problem.
He's probably thinking I'm fighting fires
and breathe in this shit in any ways
that God knows to. Would you come up
to a building, God knows what's in it,
what's on fire or what,
what was deemed safe? Yeah,
just don't light it on fire cause
immediate, all that computer shit,
plastics and all that stuff
becomes carcinogens, doesn't
it? The second it starts
in the air. What's the
most about Jesus? I Dunno.
What's the most of guys
you ever had a day?
Have you ever had two or three in a day?
I've had two back to back and then
somebody said to me one time, I said, hey,
you want to have another
one? And he goes, you know,
I never found the second set guard
to be better than the first one.
And it's just like, you
know, that's a good point.
So I always kind of keep it in that too,
but you know, I smoked them dude off.
Like I smoke them all the way
down to my fingers. Yeah, well no,
I thought I was telling somebody that's
strong. One that we had in New York.
I said when birth first lit, the strong
one, he goes, Oh man, this is strong.
And I'm thinking since I've been smoke,
cause you know when law had was in town,
Lloyd goes versus you got five and
two days like you've got to calm down.
I was going so I thought you
actually handled that one better.
You got it down to the thing. I couldn't
handle it. I'm like two years old. Yeah.
I felt like I was hot. No. Once I got
it going, I I you got it down to the,
you got it down under the
thunder, this stuff. But I wasn't,
I wasn't huffin aren't at the way I use.
A lot of that was burning. So I kind of,
I got along longer time out of it. But
when I went to light that thing, dude,
like I swear to God,
if I had a couple of scotches in me,
I probably would have puked. I felt like
I was sucking on the tailpipe of a car.
It's not like it didn't, it didn't
have a good flavor. It was just,
it was like a week, 10 years. It was like,
it was like you're eating a piece of
cake that just know. It was like Paul,
it was like putting smoke in your fucking
mouth. You know, it's bad for you.
It's just 52 times a year. I stand by
in a bus. It's delicious though. It is.
It is. And we're going to do
it. Hey, you know, my, uh,
my wife recently diagnosed
me with having fucking aid.
She's told me forever that I have add and
I never bought into it and she finally
went to the website and she read all
the things dude. And it was just like,
they might as well just had a picture
of me sitting there not listening to
somebody's focusing. It's on some
ant walking across the table, um,
before looking at something else. Do
you have that problem? I think a lot of,
a lot of myself and a lot of my comedian
friends have that. Yeah. I think it's an,
do you think that that's why we
think in bits rather than script?
I think it's because I think our
minds constantly are going, you know,
our minds are constantly going,
whether it's trying to be creative,
whether it's thinking of this,
whether it's being upset, we're just,
we can't concentrate what I was a student.
I would say we're no different than
anybody else who's scatterbrained,
which is funny. Scatterbrained
maybe. You know what I mean? Yeah.
It may cause they always try to attribute,
like they had something recently where
they tried to say that, uh, you know,
they did some study.
You know who the,
nobody knows who the fuck did it was
starting to say that, uh, you know,
they interviewed all these Comedians,
you know,
for this study to figure out
what makes comedians funny.
Now immediately I'm thinking any comedian
worth anything is not going to be
participating in that fucking thing.
Or if the new one that's struggling,
they'll participate and they're going
to give bullshit answers just to make
their friend laugh for themselves left.
Right.
So they came up with this
whole thing that, you know,
comedians are all sociopaths or some
fucking, oh, I saw it. I didn't like it.
That's ridiculous.
They,
it is because I'm not saying there
aren't comedians who are sociopaths,
but there's firemen,
there's mother's Day,
there's all kinds of people that as does
leaders of the world who are sociopaths.
It just what it is is the,
I think it's people who aren't funny.
Only somebody who was not funny
would try to figure out do that.
Why the fuck something's funny?
Absolutely. Like I wouldn't even know.
I wouldn't even like when you were talking
about that guy at the Yankee game who
kept yelling out, they had this commercial
where it was a bunch of Yankee fans.
You was saying that had spelled out
Yankees across their chest and they were
wrong. Yeah, and they were hammered or
whatever. Right. Or they just were wrong.
They were just in not organized where it
said Yankee. So it's an ant ski and ski.
So this guy at the game and a time,
anytime there was a lull in the game,
wouldn't it? No, it would.
It would. There'll be a lull
in the game and he would go,
Hey,
what the hell is that ski?
And everybody would just start laughing
and he knew when to do it. Yes.
Like that guy, he had it and
now that guy was not a comedian,
but he had that comic timing when
there was a lull on the game,
he knew it wasn't
important time in the game.
He knew probably wouldn't if there
was a TV time out. Yep. You know,
and he wanted to keep the excitement
going in people's focus like that you just
did.
It's like when I look at people who can
like just fucking play an instrument,
unbelievably played by ear, you know?
Um, that's obviously just a hobby for me.
So I have a tremendous amount of respect
for people who could do that shit.
But like they could never just
break down that. He was like,
would you just sit there and be like,
no,
look what makes this guy be able
to play the guitar like that.
It's just like this. They're good at it.
It's an envious nerd who can't do it.
That's what it is.
It's somebody who wished maybe,
maybe they wish they could do comedy,
but the fact that somebody would do a
study, comedians are all sociopaths.
That person never picked up a microphone
once in their life and maybe they,
maybe they had an issue with a
comedian. No, I'm not saying that.
I'm not a sociopath, but you, you know,
you're a family man. You got two kids.
Listen, you seem all right.
Listen, I use psychopath.
Comedians might be narcissistic.
Sociopath.
I looked up the definition of sociopath.
Okay.
There was like 11 things or something
like that that you could add to.
Let's look this up. Go it up right
now. One thing I know for a fact,
antisocial parents is one of them. Okay?
Parents, but like, I mean, antisocial,
the world's out to get, you
know, we're not going over
there. Hey, think this of us.
We're not going over. All right,
check, check one for me. What?
My parents were like, Hey, can
I go on this field trip? Nah,
Christ had a patient in the other day.
He went on a field trip and he fell
off the bus. He's gone. He's gone.
There's nothing you can do about it.
That was where my first jokes I did in
my attic. Whatever you wanted to do.
My Dad had a patient in the other day and
the kid died from it. Oh, that's funny.
Yeah. He didn't want to drive.
It's over to do it on my dad.
My Dad would now by look at it.
It's fucking hilarious.
I wouldn't do it either with one kid.
Forget about Evan fucking all
the ones he yet. Hang on a sec.
How the spot associate with sociopath,
uh, sorry. With the bed. Mike here.
Sociopath. Um, uh, traits
which I misspelled.
Sculpt traps.
How do identify as sociopath telling
signs and be, oh, what the fuck?
Why won't this work? Come on, man.
My Dad used to say people what?
He'd disagree with that they were
crazy. There we go. Crazy. They crazy.
He's a sociopath. All right, here we go.
What is it? Sociopath. That gives a fuck.
Common traits.
All right.
The common characteristics and personality
traits of sociopaths are based on the
criteria used by clinicians who
use the Dsm map. That what? That,
don't they realize morons want to
read this? I don't give a shit.
Just make a list. Yeah. They
should be just a list there.
This should dumb it down.
Right. One of the most common
personality characteristics,
sociopath is their grandiose
sense of self entitlement.
Now I don't have that and
I go the other way. Um,
sociopath off also often
display a lack of remorse. Yep.
And most have a very manipulative
personality covered by superficial charm.
Um, Jesus, I know a couple of those suit.
I know a couple of these guys
too. All right. Now wait a minute.
So I'm not no dude, you're a
narcissist who has add. Yeah,
I wouldn't be that. Yeah, I
would go with that. That's yeah,
I would totally go with that. Dude. That's
hit shit. That's hit men. I don't have,
I don't have a sense of
self entitlement. No. Dude,
I hit me and blow someone's brains
out and goes eat a sandwich.
That's a sociopath. He gets mad that
he got blood on his shirt, right? Yeah.
That was, that was that
thing in Goodfellas wins.
I'm sorry about your floor.
That's, that's it. That's what it is.
I didn't want to get blood on the
floor cause sociopaths. All right.
Friendships and romantic partners are
often frequently disregarded and replaced
when the relationship no longer
suits their self centered needs.
The emotions of associates.
Nobody even like the guy.
I was just thinking about
Bob being a sociopath. Um,
he doesn't have that.
Well I guess can you have like
most of it and then be a sociopath?
What do you think their doctor Versie
not doctor Versie I talked to by not
doctor [inaudible]. No,
I think what's it called?
I think that it's the remorse thing and
I definitely think it's the first thing
you said. The sense of entitlement.
Like this is the cool one here.
Look at this one. Jesus Christ. Cool.
Like in like a Reptilian, scary way.
The emotions of a sociopath may
appear to be sincere on the surface,
cleverly disguised by super
superficial charm and feigned interest.
Jesus Christ.
That was me and every class classroom
I ever was in sitting there acting like
you were interested so they
wouldn't fucking calling you.
Many sociopath's use manipulative
measures to draw others to them.
Chronic lying as a characteristic
of nearly all sociopath's,
recklessness and aggressive behaviors
are other characteristics as well as
impulsivity.
A lack of remorse.
He already said that or what is
generally term conscience is typical for
sociopath.
Sky's repeating himself.
The combination of at least three of the
common sociopath characteristics paints
a pretty good description
of the common sociopath. Um,
I dunno, I actually lost interest
halfway fucking through that. All right.
They did. They, I didn't,
it wasn't even trying to be
funny that came out of my mouth.
Then I realized that just did
that again. Well y'all, well,
why don't you look up to look up
a narcissist, see the difference?
Because narcissist is a selfishness,
but it's almost like a good guy. Yeah,
but dude, I'm, I'm a Gemini so I
have like, I can be really like,
I mean I think my son's a gem and a Lucas,
mainly a narcissist,
but then I could be like really
considerate and generous. Dude,
Lucas, my son Lucas is a gem and nine
he's got, when you look at what a gem,
a Geminis traits, sorry dude,
he's, he's every one of them.
She says Christ when he taken
out the crystal ball. All right,
hang on a sec. I love how I
brought up fucking crystal ball.
I love how I brought up Geminis and then
you start talking about signs and then
I act like you brought it up. Oh, all
right. Hey, how do you spell narcissist?
Go on Paul. Let's show our
dummy. R N A R narcissus.
Narcissus. I was saying an Ar, maybe what?
Ca Maybe I would've gone with that
if the right spelling didn't come up.
Narcissistic traits or
BBL Scott behaviors.
Nice assistive behaviors. All right, cool.
Narcissists have remorse.
Absolutely. Yeah, I think so.
They feel bad. They suck. Oh, here we go.
I find I found one that's dumbed
down red flags of being a narcissist.
Here we go, Dad, dad,
go ahead.
All right. All right. You feel
on edge around this person,
but you still want to,
but you still want them to like you.
What is this?
Okay,
wait, so let me, if I gotta figure,
what the fuck. Who is you in this?
So what's the difference about this list?
Well for one,
it's specifically about relationship,
but it's also about you.
Each point requires interest
section and self awareness.
Because if you want to spot toxic people,
you cannot focus entirely on their
behavior. That's only half the battle. Oh,
that's pretty cool.
He wants to also come to recognize the
looming red flags in your own heart.
All right, so this is saying if you're
in a relationship with a narcissist, it,
they don't have a list,
then I'll just go, Hey Paul,
I'm trying to make it easy here at
30 lists, like 30 things, nothing.
Um, well maybe we can actually
use our brains. It just
figured this out here with,
okay,
you feel on edge around this person,
but you still want them to like you
to use his sex as a tool for control.
CREEPO that's sick.
Plasters,
your Facebook page with compliments,
flattery songs and poems.
They text you dozens if not
hundreds of times per day.
You come to rely on this
over communication as a
source of confidence. Wow.
Oh, so they give it to you
then they take it away.
You're not texting me four times a day.
Did I do something wrong then I was up
there doing. Yeah, I'm not that. No.
I can't spell enough words to text
more than 30 times a day. All right.
Quickly declares you their soul mate.
I don't do that.
Compares you to everyone else in their
life. You just like my mother, uh,
lies
me,
my uncle Petey lies and excuses.
Why isn't excuses?
That's everybody. No,
no startle response. I,
you know, what the fuck can you just
have a one for dumb people? All right.
Here we go. Red Flag, narcissistic
behaviors. Jesus Christ.
Look at the bitches fucking picture
on this. Holy Shit. Is this about her?
She gonna tell me.
Okay.
Extreme infatuation with one self,
self centered expects to
be recognized as superior.
All right,
now you're getting warm was at you.
Now you're getting warm. No, I
don't. I don't want to be sure.
Period. I mean, you know, extreme
infatuations with one's self.
Self Center expects to be
recognized and just pictures.
Somebody combing their main in the,
with a mirror,
uh, is preoccupied with fantasies
of unlimited power, success,
brilliance,
beauty or ideal.
Love sees himself as special.
Do this.
It should only have to affiliate.
Oh Shit. This is a good one.
It's a great one.
Sees himself as special and it should
only have to affiliate with others of the
similar stature. I should
be friends with that. Obama,
I can't believe we hasn't called me yet.
That's fucking funny man.
Vantage of others takes advantage
of others to achieve his needs.
Demonstrates as an ugly one.
The other one's a funny one.
It was one takes advantage of
others to achieve his needs.
I don't like that one and that other shit.
Just staring in the mirror thing and
you should be friends with everybody.
It was big. Demonstrates a constant
need for admiration or approval.
Uh, you know, my dad used
to, we'd be upstairs shaving.
Yeah, it was sort of a joke,
but he wasn't joking,
but he was, it was funny.
We'd be downstairs eating breakfast to
south to be up there getting ready for
work and he'd be shaving in the mirror.
And then when he finished you just
hand me, be like, go look, it's a
batch. And My mother would
always laugh and shake her head,
but I think that's more, she just liked
a confident guy or something like that.
So thank you. That sounds kind
of like a gel. Like a habit.
It's a joke. Yeah. Yeah.
He's played,
he's saying it out loud,
but I actually I do that makes me laugh
all the time. I'll do it. I'll do that.
Right. Um, I'll just be like, God damn it.
I'm a good looking guy. I'll just do it.
Yeah, I'll shut up,
right? Yeah. There we go.
That'll be a reason a texted me. What
a fucking ugly bastard I am. Like,
I don't know that already.
Fuck yourself. Um,
demonstrates a constant need
for admiration or approval.
Exaggerates personal achievements
while minimizing those.
That's fucking hilarious. I want to
be around this guy. I'll tell you,
you know, it's great. It's great the
way you came up with a game plan,
but it's just good the way I
was cheering crowd. Oh Dude.
I got this chant going. I tell you,
I could see it in Tom Brady's face.
He knew, he knew by what I
was doing in the crowd. Yeah.
And then he tries to knock the other
guys changing. He keep, keep calling.
He called an audible, you know,
which I wouldn't have done.
I would've stuck with
the play and then no,
but then it says he diminishes the
other guy. The guys chant was all right,
but I got more of them
going. Yeah, I got it.
And that guy came up to me at the
end of the game was just like gray.
I don't usually say this,
but you were amazing.
You go with this list is great.
You know why this is is because this
reminds me of so many guys that I used to
hang out with and gamble with and all
that type of shit. Like all these guys,
like this is a brutal, if you're a
narcissist, you walked into a fuck casino.
It's fucking brutal.
Cause you're gonna walk in thinking
you're James Bond and you have this system
and you're going to take the
whole fucking house down. Yeah.
I gotta tell you there's nothing funnier
than that one that you read that said
that they think they're superior,
so they should only be hanging
out with people that are superior.
That it's so fucking funny and
hilarious. Yeah. Oh, um, all right.
Is convinced that he slash she is unique.
Yeah.
I liked how that just suggests. That
just takes it, we're all special.
This websites like, no, you're not,
feels entitled to special treatment and
that rules frequently don't apply to him.
Um, I don't have the first half,
but I have the second house I have,
I have problems with authority.
I definitely do.
Okay.
I told you that story right where I
didn't if I told you that fucking story,
right? Oh yeah. I didn't
get caught either.
My proposed love and marriage within
only a few weeks might I'll may propose
love and marriage with only with,
but then only a few weeks of starting a
relationship that definitely wasn't me.
Very charismatic and charming at first,
but can quickly switch from doctor
[inaudible]. Hi, this is fucking ladies.
These are all just the same thing over
and over again. Oh wait, panics. Cries,
begs and becomes emotional. If he
anticipates an end to a relationship,
that's not, I swear to God, I'll pay
attention to you more. I was wrong.
What do you want me to show you?
I was wrong.
May Harass or stock you
if you do break up. Oh,
cause he wants to be the one who breaks
up or she quick to anger or feeling
salted or slided rages with anger or
inflicts the Silent Treatment went upset.
A Ding, Ding, ding, Ding, Ding. I
got that quick to anger. I got that.
I wouldn't stock somebody denies he
slash she has issues to work to work on.
That's fucking sees himself
or herself as nearly perfect.
I fucking love this guy. What are
you talking about? He talk already.
That's so funny. Maybe you want to
work on yourself. Adapt around me.
Drives recklessly in a way too fast.
Exaggerate this exaggerates
the truth or blatantly lies.
Dude, I want to be around this guy and
just listening to him tell stories.
This is the funniest shit. Rarely
treats anyone with respect or kindness.
Does it exist?
College doesn't acknowledge
or respect others' boundaries.
Always wants to be in control. May
drink and drive regularly. Yeah.
Cause he doesn't give a
fuck about other people.
His slash her need for attention,
time and space and matter. Um,
okay.
Oh, his need for ty for attention,
time and space matter. Yours.
Your needs do not.
Um,
let me just read one more of
these before this gets boring.
Uses sex as a weapon through withholding,
controlling,
or being overly demanding.
I said socket,
the best dick ever
doesn't appear to have a conscious,
does not take criticism well and becomes
easily defensive as easily hurt and
insulted Jesus Christ. That's what,
that was a fucking hilarious list.
Oh really funny. I love
that is funny though. Huh?
Sees themselves as superior and should
only be hanging around superior beings.
That's all right. Let me, let me read.
I got to do a little, I got
to do the other fucking, uh,
okay.
Advertising here.
Where the hell am I?
Yeah.
All right. I got two more, right? Two
more. Two more on to ready break. Okay.
Legal Zoom, everybody. The
excitement of starting your business,
getting your first customer,
and finally quitting your job
hasn't moved you to action yet.
Here's another great, what it
should say. If we're missing the,
if starting over legal zoom,
take to legal zoom everybody.
If the excitement of starting your own
business, getting your first customer,
and finally quitting your Goddamn Day job.
Has it moved you to action yet?
Here's another great reason
to get started, dude.
I need some fucking water.
Just talk to the people here for a second.
All right. Tell him what you got. Yeah.
Going off on a Monday morning
podcast listeners here.
What do you want to come and see me?
Well, you know what, I want to be,
you got going on. Go
ahead. I'm going to be,
what do you mean I'm going to be
in fucking Canada with you? Um,
I'm going to be out here in Canada with
bill until March 21st everybody away
from my wife and kids and,
uh,
with this maniac for the next fucking
two and a half weeks and you know
something,
the more I think about it,
if you think I'm doing water for the
next two and a half fucking weeks,
it's on tonight. Um, I'm
tapping out 53 days. That's it.
That's it. You call it,
he called it stops here.
It all of a sudden my fucking
throat got really dry.
Okay.
All right, let's try this again. Take
three legal zoom. Have you buddy.
If the excitement of
starting your business,
getting your first customer and finally
quitting your job hasn't move you to
action yet. Here's another
great risk reason. Um,
it's national starch.
Your business month and legal zoom wants
to help you start your own corporation
or LLC or file a DBA so you can get
up and running quickly and easily.
Find out why more than 1 million
entrepreneurs use legal zoom.
Just start down the path of successful
businesses. Business ownership, sorry.
This month only take advantage
of their national starch,
your business month special and get a
free three month trial of all the new
quickbooks making it so much
easier to run your new business.
That's $119 value for absolutely free.
How do you get it while
you type in burpee?
You are are in the
referral box at checkout.
That's legalzoom.com Promo Code burr legal
zoom helps provide self-help services
and can connect you with the right
attorney, but they're not a law firm.
legalzoom.com Promo Code
[inaudible], B, U, R,
R and last but not least,
Hulu plus. All right,
you've probably tried
hulu.com now with Hulu plus,
you can watch your favorite shows anytime,
anywhere.
Hulu plus lets you watch thousands hit
TV shows and a selection of a claim,
movies on your television or on the go
with your smartphone or tablet and it all
streams in HD for the best
viewing experience with Hulu.
Plus you can watch your favorite current
TV shows like Saturday night live
community and family guy.
You can also check out exclusive
content including Hulu originals,
like the office starring Snl,
Seth Meyers and mood boys' starring
Chris O'Dowd from bridesmaids.
Hulu plus also offers a great selection
of acclaimed films for only seven 99 a
month. You can stream as many
TV shows and movies as you want,
wherever you want right now. You can
try Hulu plus for free for two weeks.
When you go to Hulu plus.com/bill
that's a special offer for my listeners.
Make sure you use Hulu plus.com/bills
so you get the extended free trial and
that they know that I sent you there.
Go to Hulu plus.com/bill now click
on the Hulu plus banner on the
podcastPage@billbird.com uh oh,
there's one more here. Sorry.
Hang on. I gotta get some water here.
Nailed that one. Did I? Yeah, that,
that was fucking dead. You know
that like a split off. Alright.
He voice eve voice.
Everybody.
You are a business owner but automated
phone systems and secretaries aren't in
your budget just yet.
And juggling incoming calls yourselves
makes it hard to look like a professional.
Here's something that will dramatically
help you make more money in 2014 what is
it? Well, it's a voice. Everybody,
whether you're a business of one or 100
he voice will help you manage all of
your incoming calls with the
toll free number, dial by name,
directory and call routing tools. Your
business will sound like 1 million bucks.
Can't take the call, no problem. He voice.
We'll transcribe the voicemail and
email it right to you so you'll never be
caught off guard again and with the voice
you can try it before you buy it right
now.
Just for my listeners,
you can get a 60 day trial to eat voice
for absolutely free. How do you get it?
You go to [inaudible] dot com and you
went to the Promo Code Bill B I l l at
checkout.
Take Shit a take charge of your business
and make more money in 2014 go to
[inaudible] dot com and enter bill at
checkout for your 60 day free trial.
That's he voiced.com Promo
Code Bill Jesus Christ.
I've got the hiccups halfway
through that. Um, it's better. Good.
He usually do well, you know, I
read the same copy every week.
I think I get it down by now. Oh, you
do? It's like it doesn't change for,
for the most part it does. Where I
fucked up, I fucked up. It shouldn't be.
It should.
All right.
Okay,
let's go. Let's go here. Time travel.
MMM.
Time travel. Billy thrills. Um,
if you could travel to any time period
period prior to 1900 but you were forced
to live out your life there and you
couldn't come back to the present,
where would you choose to go?
Keep in mind anything before 1900 means
everyone probably smells and dies it 40
years of age. That's not true. Not
if you have money. You live long.
Ben Franklin look for a long time and
he was a fucking booze bag out there.
Flying.
Is Kate in the rain?
Did he live long? Yeah. Yeah. He lived
to like be like 70. Oh Wow. Yeah.
And he went out there with this kite in
the rain and he was fucking shit faced.
So he got his house
keys tied to the thing.
That's the real story of how we discovered
electricity was fucking hammered you
serious? Yeah, he was out of his fucking
mind. And if he was actually stone sober,
he probably would have died because
he would attend stuff when he got
electrocuted. But cause he was drunk,
he was all relaxed like hey man.
And he just rolled down the hill,
landed on his ball.
That's actually how he went bald.
He went down the hill,
like one of the lightning struck,
they hit the Keenan boobs.
It's off his head off. What new
studies have shown all of this. Oh,
I thought it was just fucking male pattern
baldness. No, that's he got elected. No,
like 30% of people, this is the
worst thing they never talk about.
If you get struck by
lightning like you Amit,
that blows off that top
part. You serious? Yeah.
And it doesn't come back either.
It wouldn't make a difference with me,
but that's why Mike Michael
Bolton does that cherry.
He does that charity thing for a,
don't tell me he does a charity for
people that get struck by lightening.
Got their hair blown.
I can't believe you believe in this shit.
I'm just making all this up.
The fucking top of the head. You know
it doesn't, but does he have a charity,
Michael Boat? Yeah. Yeah,
but not for that. No. Oh,
I fucking committed to
that. I did. All right,
let's continue.
Dude, that was getting so deep. I
couldn't keep a straight face. I'm like,
there's no way he's believing this one.
All right, this one, get it down the hill.
I said, that's how he went bald. And they
go, no, no, wait, here's a better life.
You still like really? Is that
what happened? Jesus Christ.
Paul, what's the world
coming to? All right Paul,
if you could live any time period
before 1900 anywhere. Anytime.
Oh Man. Where would you go? I don't know.
I would go somewhere where there was
a war, but wait, but in the question,
can I take things from present?
Okay,
well, let's see. You could
time travel to any period. 1900
so what the fuck would you bring here?
The second you pulled anything out,
they think you were a
witch and they kill you.
What I'm saying is I would go to there
with like shit that they don't have now.
That's what I'm saying. Like in a
war though, and I fucking just lace.
Like if I took a side,
you know,
you go with a couple uzis or a fucking
machine gun. He just fucking lady.
You wouldn't, you'd be a fucking God
forever. It'd be a hero. You know?
You'd be like, you'd be
God, what are you gonna do?
You're just going to walk out in the
field and use Nike fucking sweatshirt.
It Jordan's. Yeah, just walk out dress
like this. And they would be like,
you know when they were packing muskets
and doing the whole thing and I'd be
like, no, not all guys. I got this
what year? What year? I just fucking,
and they would be like, oh my God,
but just be the fucking man forever.
That'd be the man forever.
You imagine that?
Yeah.
I'm trying to wrap my head around where
they're not completely freaked out by
you. You're going to go
first of all, first of all,
what year are you going back to? Well,
he said why? He said prior 1900 yeah.
So what year are you going
back to the pack and Musket?
So what are we talking here? Well,
there was a couple of one there. Oh,
what is it like 18 like 1817 1870s right.
Well by 1870s they had like
the Winchesters and those
repeating rifles and that
they actually had their first
machine gun in the civil war,
I believe Spanish American.
Anyways, we had the little frank,
if you fucking mowed them down,
I go before that time then.
So you're talking like I, if I was
you I would go early 18 hundreds okay.
So I'd go early 18 hundreds yup.
And I would bring some sort of,
who are you going to mow down?
Um,
what if you went in the French and Indian
war and you actually found on the side
of the Indians what year was just
mowed down? A bunch of French people,
whichever side.
I decided to choose,
like when I got there and they saw that
I showed up from a time machine, right.
One group's going to be
nicer to me right now.
They're all going to be
completely freaked out by you.
There's going to be to you as a threat
and you'll probably have to turn your Uzi
on them.
Then you'd have to steal their clothes
and then try to fucking do an accent.
I would choose a side of the
people that were the nicest,
warmest to me when I got there, and then
I would fucking become their savior.
Nobody's going to be nice to Paul.
You understand that? If I did it,
they would rewrite the book on me.
They would. They would be a mythical I,
they would kill you. No, I would, they
would kill you, Paul. They would kill you.
They would tell Steve what
happened to Jesus. No, they would.
What happened to Jesus? They
got crucified. Okay. So yeah,
but you're going to run out of bullets.
So now, but I'm just in the question.
It doesn't specify like what I'm
coming with. I'm going to go prepare.
How big is this fucking time
machine? No, no, no, no.
I'm going to go with like a bunch
of clips and a couple of Uzis. Okay.
And they're gonna write fucking stories
about me being be mass murdering psycho
from the fucking future. And it go
some mythical wearing lazy, close,
lazy at the close though.
Some Italian do front of you or they're
not even know what New York is. Oh,
actually maybe the other [inaudible] yeah.
Do you, you're not listening. You Paul.
This is the key. They wouldn't all kill
me, but Paul is saying, I'm here to help.
Listen, listen, I got, I came
to this, I can't listen to
what I would tell him. Okay.
And then you tell him what
you'd say. I say, look,
I came from the future to help you.
This machine brought me here to help you.
I'm going to solve your problems. And
then I would fuck a pull out. Okay.
And let me ask you this, wealth
live this. Let's do this.
Let's say fucking after this tour,
you can't sleep one night and you look
out your back yard and you see this
fucking thing appear out of nowhere and
this guy gets out and starts walking
towards your fucking
house from a time machine
and let's just say you have a shotgun and
this guy walks up. He goes, no, no. Hey,
listen,
Paul Paul and he's wearing these weird
workout clothes from 300 years in the
future. Listen, I'm here to help you.
I'm here to do things
that you're going to like.
You're going to fucking trust this guy.
I don't know because I was
sleeping in my bed and and I'm not.
I'm talking about I want
to show up into a conflict.
I want to show up to the moment of a
conflict and fucking take a side and when
it, I want to win the game for
the team. This is what I'm saying.
It's a very narcissistic
behavior here, Paul. You know,
you think he's just going
to show up on a battlefield.
They're going to be like our brain show
up and you fucking walk out of this
thing with yet, but he's sweatshirt
and a fucking Uzi and the, no,
the, the union army and the rebels are
not like one of them is going to win.
One of them's going to embrace you.
Yeah.
One of those groups are losing
fathers and sons and I go,
I got this fuck the musket and I just
fucking, I just fucking lays out an army.
They're going to look at me like, dude,
this guy, where are they going to do?
They're going to go that we've been saved
this. Once they realize you are mortal,
they would fucking,
probably they would.
They would take your weapons is what
they would do. How they getting to you?
Is He from me?
If they're fucking packing a musket and
they have knives because what are you
talking and Paul, because you're going
to have your fucking back to him.
If he's shooting at the other guy,
Paul, you know what they're going to do.
They're going to probably at nice to you.
This would be okay.
And then what they're going to do is
they're going to try to figure out where
the fuck you came from.
They're good immediately confiscate your
fucking time machine and they're going
to try to see if they can duplicate it.
Salts weight so they can
run the fucking world.
How are they going to confiscate the time
machine from me when I'm the one with
the ammo? I'm the one with
the semiautomatic weapons.
I'm the one who's just say,
well, are they going to do, what
are they going to do? Paul is,
they're gonna fucking put an all points
bulletin out on every fucking Goddamn
tree out there wanted
sweatpant guy from the future.
This man alone has been in this time
zone is error for fucking 20 minutes and
it's already killed
600 feet.
No,
but here's the thing.
The question was where would you
go and if you couldn't come back,
if I survived this all did you, did
you, did you see? Did forget about,
I know you didn't read
anything in history. Let's
just, let's just talk. Okay.
Yeah.
World War II.
There's muskets in 1870
fuck packs and the guns,
I mean in 1870. I just laughed.
So hard to see in dots. No. Um,
world war two I read about,
I read about shit.
You literally sound like you sitting on
a stoop right now. I know stuff. God,
what was the question?
I was going to ask him.
I was going to talk about people in
history, but how about let's just,
we'll go with movies. All right.
Right. You saw there will be blood.
Yes. Okay. That's based
off like the robber barons,
uh, of, of the fucking,
you know, 17, 1800. The uh,
the people you've got involved in oil
rig, the railroad guys, the Rockefellers,
the Vanderbilts, the fucking people
who like fucking at all. Yeah. Yeah.
They came over here. Right. They
fucking got it. You know, they just,
it was wide open. You could do
whatever the fuck you want and they,
they did it right. All right.
This is funny. I've made
fun of you for being stupid.
I can't even explain this.
These guys,
the JP Morgans and all
these types of fuck guys.
When you show up with this machine
where they can fucking change the past,
they can change the fucking future.
These sociopath psychos
are not going to let you,
Paul Versey. Once they fucking sit
down and they talk to you, Paul,
take day.
See where the fuck you're at.
They will pretend to be friends with
you and when the second you set down you
your Uzi to have a little bit of mutton
with them at the villa for us today with
cut you ear to ear. Oh
No, no. First of all,
I'm too fucking street smart to ever
put my o down and let them find,
start fucking drinking tea
and crumpets with these.
I don't like how you think you're street
smart and every fucking error like you
know what the signs are in 1812 you think
I'm going to leave my fucking Uzi down
when nobody's got one that's gold to
those people. That's, that's, that's,
that's ends, that's ends
problems. I would never do that.
So you going to become
friends with these people?
Always having a gun trained on them.
That's what you're telling me. I said,
how about this?
This is what I could also do.
I could get there in my time machine and
I could befriend one person and I could
let them know that I'm here to help them
if they need and tell them what I could
do. And then maybe they can say, hey
listen, when we get into, you know,
when the rebels come, I've got a guy,
you know what, I wasn't listening.
I was thinking about what I
was going to do. All right,
well what would you do this,
what I would go back to once in 1900,
I would go back and keep in
mind anything before eight,
prior to 1900, I would
go back to 1899. Okay.
Cause I want the most up to date and
medical fucking shit available for when I
come down with polio. Whatever
bullshit that's going to hit me. Um,
I would,
I would do is I would try out and make
a major league baseball team and I would
fucking destroy them with my, uh,
with my knowledge of nutrition,
my a hundred 120 years in the future.
If my knowledge of nutrition,
you know what I would do,
I would take some PE days back with me
before they even know how to test for it
and I would fucking roid
up fucking just give I,
Bruce and I would try out for the Boston
Red Sox and we would win it for every
fucking year, right through the
twenties. That's a great idea.
And that's what I would do. But you'd
have to go back with sterile. Yeah.
You'd have to go back.
You'd have to convince these
people that you're going to inject.
Still don't think I could
hit a curve ball. Huh?
I still don't think I could
hit a fucking curve ball,
but I just figured if I went back to
the fucking, I couldn't make them.
I couldn't make a major league baseball
team in the 19 hundreds but I think I
could make one in the 1890 so just I
would have me go back. When did it start?
1880 join the fucking Phillies.
I wouldn't want them to win a
championship, but who I want what?
Whenever the one of the fucking red
sox come around, there was the first,
see the red sox came around in what
the and the 18 early 19 hundreds
okay.
I'd like to play whenever they,
they built Fenway in 1912 I would just
like to come up to bat. God dammit.
I couldn't do it so I'd have to go back,
but I'm my age now.
I'd be too fucking old by then.
Okay.
Fuck him. He can still kill it
though. This is what I would do.
I become totally fluid in the Latin and a,
I would fucking go back and I'd
watch a game at the Roman Colosseum.
That's fine. I'm trying to sports related,
I would just take my chances with,
I would just go with the heavy artillery.
I would be, I would be a defense.
I would be, you know, I'm going to Ronald
Reagan route, just spend it, all of them,
all the money on defense.
I would hope that they would utilize
me that way as an asset military wise.
You know, dude, you're out
of your mind dude. Why?
Like just me going back thinking
that I could fucking make a team.
Cause I looked at Benton, those 1890s
like did, they were like softball teams,
so just hadn't ringers there. That's, you
know, all those guys didn't stretch do,
but you know, you just went up
to your neck in a wild west days.
They fucking went outside and they
went back to back and then 10 paces.
I fucking get rid of that man. I'm talking
about, I have everything. I'm an ass.
Don't have anything. Paul, what
you have is a gun and bullets.
You have the best gun,
right? With the best bullets.
But you're ignoring the fact that an
entire army is going to go after you,
that they're not going to allow,
they're not going to allow you.
They wouldn't allow you to take power.
By the way,
for the way that you seize power.
As you assimilate and you work your way
up through the ranks and then you have a
you,
you and you strike when the time is right.
That's how you try and start
your own shoe. Come in,
they're all rogue and I was like,
listen,
I have better shit than you guys could
ever dream of having, but don't worry.
I'm your friend. These fucking paranoid
assholes, these control freaks, this,
they want that you could not live.
They would be smearing you in in the the,
the paper with every fucking day.
Just talking about this reminds me of
that shoe or a big of a threat than the
savages that need to be
clear. They, they, they would,
they would put you above getting rid
of native Americans at that point.
You would have to be eliminated,
but not before they found out how took
apart the gun to figure out how it works.
Tortured you for all the fucking,
um,
knowledge that you had an and grilled
you about that time machine to figure out
if you built it or you
just fucking used it.
So what if I lied to him and I
said I could get more of this.
I got a time machine.
Nobody knows where it is,
but I could go back and get more of
this like, so if they knew that I could,
I could, you know what I mean? If
I lied on that, that's the best.
That's the best move.
You've said out of all of this
scenario where maybe you know, you,
you could do a play on their greed
and their desire to have more.
That's actually a smart fucking move.
But if you just think that you're just
going to show up with your fucking cigar
and your Uzi and come walking out
on a battlefield, do this sketch,
I'll just want to do this and just change
the course of history depending on who
was nicer to you. What if the Germans
were nice view and World War Two. I mean,
you know they had nice uniforms. Paul,
you're going to sign with them. It would.
How funny would it be?
Just watching me going there with
air maxes on Nike Air Max is honest,
the Gar and it's the white chair
and I'm like, listen, sit down.
I got a gun that could solve it and
I just show the guy I would love to.
I would fucking love to see the looks
on their faces and then all of a sudden
they rebelled against me. I think
if, I think if you actually,
if you actually went out there and you
mowed down the whole other side with what
you had. Yeah, that was my original.
That's what I would think
that if I was on the,
on my side. Are you on your side? Yeah.
I would slowly be backing away as you
were doing it and then I would slip into
the woods and fucking run
away is what I would do.
I would get the fuck away
from you because I don't pull.
You understand what the fuck I'm seeing.
Okay.
You can show up in your space
close with your fucking ray gun.
I mean, it's just like I'm out of
there. I'm fucking out of there.
I'm going to leave and if you come
towards me, I'm going to shoot. I mean,
if a fucking alien landed and I had a gun,
fuck his ray guns.
Fuck all that bullshit. If it starts
coming towards me, I got to shoot at it.
If that happened,
I'd be living in the biggest house in
the 18th so I'd have all the women would
be fine. I would be the fucking Jesus
there. They would fucking draw pictures.
Do you know what it is,
Paul?
This is your own little narcissistic
head trip and that's the exact thing that
would bring you down.
You know something?
I think that this is a great answer
to your listener. As questionable.
You're acting. You aren't in
love about all of this, Paul.
You're acting like you know
how to make a fucking Uzi. No,
I'm saying what time machine
you're going to bring one.
So he did was bring it and they're going
to figure it out because the scientists
back then were just as
brilliant as a scientist.
Now they just don't have the
information that the ones do today.
So they would immediately break down
your fucking what you are that you're a
stand up comedian. That's what they
would do. Well, what are you going to do,
Paul? What are you gonna do for food?
You're going to Uzi at deer. Okay.
And then do you know how to start a
fire without some wood prominent ticket?
You know how to do that?
Yeah. How do you do it?
You know how to start a fire without
matches. Yeah, I mean I've seen it done.
I've watched it on TV. I've seen it on the
fucking, I've seen it on youtube. I did.
I fucking see it on youtube when we
ran a matches at the house one time.
I swear to God, I was watching a
clip. Yeah, I've watched it too. Yeah,
the guy sat down, yet he gets to
the driest, whatever they call it,
the grass or the dry fucking Paul.
I'm gonna tell you this right now.
If you can make, if you could start
a fire and twist the thing, right?
If you could start a fire tonight.
All right,
we'll go to the Toronto Central Park. If
you could start a fight, a fight, a fire,
I'll give you all the money.
I'm going to make it on this tour with
don't watch the youtube video again.
I want to see you start this fucking far.
Okay.
And if you don't some wood or is down,
if you don't,
then you have to walk into the fucking,
into the Lake Ontario with
the Jordan Song 30 and shit.
Well that's the point I want.
You don't want you to stop.
You're hilarious. You're like, yeah,
you did see it. Wow. All right,
let's go with baby names
named Jesus Christ. This is
becoming a long one here. Um,
all right, baby names.
Uh, dear Billy trimester.
My wife and I are
expecting our first child.
We don't know whether
it's a boy or a girl,
but we're starting to talk about names.
My inclination is to go with the name
that's not trendy, but not super common.
Like Mike, she's whoever
wrote this. I like, uh,
but part of me is like, Eh, fuck
it named the Kid Hendricks or wolf,
something he can take to the playground
and build a reputation around, uh,
what would be your strategy? Oh, you're
the parent. Paul, what do you think?
Uh, what she said about the whole mic
thing is exactly what me and Stacy said.
You know what he said? Well,
what he said, um, my, uh,
when my wife was pregnant with
Lucas, you know, I didn't want,
I just didn't want George
Mike, you know, Joey Anthony,
I just didn't want that.
You know, I wanted something
different and uh, I agree.
I mean, wolf and Hendrix is a little
much, you know, calling your kid wolf,
he's going to get fucked. You know that
they mean it's, it's, it's a bad ass name.
But if he's not bad
ass, it's fucked. Like,
if he's in percent IOM or if he's a
fucking, his name is wolf. Yeah, no,
you can't have a singer named Wolf, you
know, fucking it becomes an opera star.
He had the fucking Wolf Gang
Fun. Um, I like that though.
I don't like super common, but I
don't like, you know, you know what,
what's her name? Gwyneth Paltrow.
Apple or fuck cocoa or something crazy.
So I think it's something respectful,
really nice, you know? Uh, yeah,
but the thing is you got to make sure
you pick the right one where you know,
like, I remember for a minute, remember
those, those Dylan Dakota years,
everybody was naming and the kid
said, bullshit. Takota fucking Tanner.
Tanner.
It was a little bad one.
What was what Tom Tyler and I don't
know if Tyler's Tyler is fine.
Tyler's all right. But uh, how about
one of those? We didn't get Bryce.
I hate, I hate to be once that me too.
I don't like him. No. Yeah, me too. Oh,
I am one. I'm a mainstream one. I
don't mind bill Bob that bullshit.
But like I, it was like, who the fuck does
that? Like the name like they have like,
or Roger Clemens,
you know,
named all his kids began with a k because
he strikes everybody out there talking
about sociopath. We'll
fucking narcissist. Right.
Everything Oldie Kyle. Yeah. Everything.
Everything had to do with K. Yeah.
Cunt.
Um,
um, anyways. Yeah. I Dunno. I Dunno
why we, you know, we actually, uh,
I've talked about that type of shit.
I don't know, man. I don't, that's,
that's a tough one.
I know somebody who'd be selfish cause
it's not about you and those Hollywood
people that name the fucking names.
It's about them. It's about them.
And it shouldn't be, you know, this
person does this, this and that.
You have to live with this
person's going to school,
this person's going to be traveling.
This person's going to have their name
called out in public many, many times.
Their name is going to be red.
So you can't look at what's
it. Oh, hang on, hang on.
I'm going to look up a
bad celebrity baby names.
All right.
Bad Celebrity kid names.
A lot of people go with destination.
We're celebrity baby names. You know,
there'd be something out
there. All right, here we go.
This is a very listy
this week. Um hmm. Huh?
Come on load. You fucking
Cock sucker. I'm actually, uh,
I'm loading some video right
now, um, to be posted on the,
on the podcast page of the Oval and
Halifax and actually you skating.
Oh yeah, go ahead. Yeah,
he posted at God. God. God,
what the fuck are they?
Oh,
you fucking cunt.
Why?
Why do I want it to load the worst
celebrity baby names? Here it is.
I think the first one is apple.
Oh,
tomorrow.
You just know that the name came
up during a drunken precon t u oh,
tomorrow. Oh No. Why would
you do that? What is it?
The guy's name is rob
morrow. Amaro. I Dunno.
And they named their kid to
tomorrow. Ugh. That's awful.
UF eaten woefully coming out tomorrow.
Alright.
Zuma,
Nesta rock.
Gwen Steffani and Gavin Ross.
Rossdale Gwen. Okay, sure.
Zuma is the name of a beach in Malibu.
That's lovely.
But it's also a computer game.
I thought it was a fucking drank Zima
and the dominion of form of a term for a
bad gastro and testicles.
Uh,
Jesus Christ Zuma.
Well,
what's it called?
The Kim Kardashian and Gillette
named his kid moxy crime fighter.
That's fucking awful.
That's a selfish fucking move.
That says a fucking selfish. Well, what a
fucking asshole. Um, I shouldn't say that.
Jason Lee named a kid pilot inspector
pilot.
How do you not just be an arrogant
ass if your name is pilot? Is that it?
What do we got? An App, car
dash and aimed at northwest.
That's more of like a direction airline.
Yeah. I just, you know, this girl
named her fucking kid audio science.
There's, this is a sociopath
thing we're talking about.
Isn't this kind of like a
cruelty? Some. This is ridiculous.
All right. Somebody named the Kid
heavenly. Her Ranney tiger lily.
I mean, are these jokes like, yeah,
why don't you just name your kid douche
bag or something like that and just get
it over with?
Police punched me in the face.
I think it would be hot about this one.
Fifi Trixie bell.
These are not even like,
like if a southern guy went
fucking like Bogart, Bogart,
navy shitty food.
I have named a dog that
Bogart shape pot pot.
That's terrible.
Do celebrities actually think
that children's have super
this person? Oh, cal El.
I don't know. I don't know what the
fuck that means. I don't know cal,
you know cal L is, no, I don't, you know.
No, I don't. I'm going into superheroes.
Kel.
Ella's superman.
Superman's father.
Oh,
I believe. Oh my God. Something would
superman. Somebody named their kid hero.
Okay.
How would you do that?
You better be tough.
Bronx Mogil Bronx isn't a bad name.
You just can't,
you just can't live in New York.
Bronx is a terrible name
bill. Oh yeah. Well, I mean,
after fucking seeing some of the other
ones, it's not bad. Right? I mean,
it's better than pilot and,
but it's still fucking
diva thin muffin. No,
it's nice what it got.
Why
diva thing sounds like a way for
all right. This is actually getting,
this is just said buddy bear.
All right, I'm done. All right.
This is just bad. Well, let's,
let's, uh, what happened is podcasts,
you were just fucking sitting there
going on and on here. Ah, all right.
Documentary recommendation.
This is the last thing. Bill,
have you seen the act of killing?
Have you seen that?
Paul did and I heard it was great.
Yeah. He goes, I can't even explain it.
You just have to watch it.
Basically in the 60s and Indonesia,
they were enforcers that murdered people
for being communists in quotes who
idolized American gangster culture.
So picture of five foot five Asian dude
trying to walk like Humphrey Bogart.
I got to watch it. All right. Guess what,
people, that's the podcast for this week.
Uh, Paul, thanks for uh, being a guests
had a blast. Thanks for having me, man.
Yeah. So next week I'll do your
podcast and hopefully, dude,
I hope you know tonight when
we fall off the fucking wagon,
it's going to be epic. I hope that we,
this is not a blitzkrieg of drunk stories.
Next week ads. I just, Nah,
we'll fine. We'll be fine. Yeah.
Everything that we've done in the past,
fine,
we've demonstrated that we can
handle alcohol. Right. What do we do?
Plugs now. Yeah. What are you plugging?
Well, I'm going to be here, uh,
21st with you. So just, just
check the fuck Eddie ago website.
Then I'm going out to la. We'll talk
about that on the next one, right? Yeah.
I want to have like, I want to have a hair
restoration. No, you don't. No, no, no.
I don't want to, I want to have
a fuck. I need one, but I, I,
I want to have a hair restoration person,
uh,
advertise on this.
So then,
then have him come on so they can
give their hair plug. Oh. Oh, Jesus.
No.
When I came back to New
York, if you guys, anybody,
anybody listening in the New York,
New Jersey area,
I'm going to be at levity
live on the 21st to the 23rd,
and you could check that out. Please
check out my podcast. The Versie effect.
Bill's been on it a few times.
It's doing really well. Um,
you guys check it out on iTunes and
it's also on pod bean. Um, I just,
in my hundred and 50th episodes, we'll
check out the, if you're bragging. Yeah,
check out the visit. It's
doing well. I got to pump it.
Just Fall Paul by himself. Not,
yeah, sometimes I have a guest,
I have a guest every like 10
episodes, but it's me. I talk movies,
I talk sports.
I do an unacceptable for the week,
which is something that just bugs me.
Um,
so check that out and get me on Twitter
at Paul Versey. That's v I. R. Z.
I always unacceptable. You
know, it was unacceptable. I,
it's an airplane thing line and Paul's
fucking sitting across me on the island.
Some lady shows up goes,
do you mind switching seats so I can
sit next to my daughter? Paul says,
fine.
Her fucking daughter had a middle seat
hall traded isle on a packed flight and
does, Darla was like, what, 16, 17,
it's a fucking adults through
67. And I said, sure ma'am.
And then I sat in the other aisle
seat and the guy goes, Nah, guy does.
I think you're in the middle. Awful,
unacceptable. Totally unacceptable.
We're an hour and 42 minutes and we got
a game to go to and I got to get this
podcast up. All right, brother. I'll, uh,
I'll fucking talk to you in the second,
and this is over.